c'était dans la cinquième et la bande
est gentil ah ouais ouais
oui l'ambiance n'a pas dit alors tu sais
pourquoi aussi parce que où la vapeur le
mec derrière toi là évoluent regarde pas
si ça fait très film de tutu c est donc
l or je continue alors en fait la
différence si tu veux tu as éclats
autour de toi t'as que des artistes
c'est ça donc c'est vraiment le métier
des chroniqueurs c'est une chose au
moins est grave c'est pas possible moi
qui ai pas vus depuis longtemps mais la
série ne tombe pas je te jure ou maçon
de visite
peut-être qu'ils seront pas qu'aux
chercheurs mais je n'ai pas rêvé il y
avait un mec il est descendu ferté cas
pour gagner encore dudu du speed sueur
perler ce rêve mais c'est sûr que cette
annonce était génial j'adore
si vous deviez vous tous je te prends
mais regagnait il revient et il nous
faut pas casser des vitres comme ça deux
précédentes et on aurait dit moi j'adore
j'adore l'idée
dix ans je veux venir chez toi tous les
jours voici joie des sectes ou le temps
regard non c'est pas possible c'est
génial
[Musique]
c'était donc ce soir c'est la grosse
rigolade et ouais j'ai justement à faire
des choses ensemble pour tous mais quand
tu quand tu sembles là alors je me dis
qu'elle y autorise ce que je peux te
retrouver
moi personnellement il ya plusieurs
trucs j'aimerais faire céder des
saynètes pour netflix mais c'était
immonde il faut que tu produis ya
monsieur nu et il m'a fait une grille
vos crimes qu une grive aux tripous et
son fils chéri envoyer tous cette
troisième jambe
ouais ça va tomber sur moi écoute je
sais pas te dire que j'ai fait je
réajuste 10 km balade je crois qu'il
revient dans un endroit aujourd'hui un
lien
[Musique]
ce soir jusqu'à ce qu'un même pas ces
gens me donnent leur temps à me dire tu
déconnes ouais ok tu fais quoi bon avoir
le bon goût de l'ag le vendredi avec toi
dans l'enceinte 2,8 et jeremy tan
support derrière ça vient faire là mais
la mauvaise pression gênée car oui oui
bon match et maintenant le champ période
de jachère je pense que c'est dur c'est
la ville de l'amour ça surtout que c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis qu'il avait carouge et
l'homme à l'air je suivais les mystères
demande comment 3par tu peux combien
d'épisodes quai de dell 2,2 des visites
à faire un truc avec mon fils je te
dirais qu'à des jeunes à des grosses
roues puis on a déjà vu des impacts sur
gamecube hamza en l'air je n'arrive pas
d'ici tant du mérite du monde
bravo